Florida once again the epicenter of a
major post-election battle allegations
of fraud now being thrown around as two
key races move closer toward recounts
vote counting can issues in Broward and
Palm Beach counties causing Senate
candidate Rick Scott to file lawsuits
accusing officials thereof trying to
steal the election there may be rampant
fraud happening in Palm Beach and
Broward counties and the Broward
Supervisor of Elections Brenda Snipes
has a history of acting in absolute bad
faith Florida law which requires that
vote by mail and absentee ballots are
counted within 30 minutes of polls
closing I will not sit idly by while
unethical liberals try to steal this
election Sarah Nelson hired one of
Hillary Clinton's lawyers from DC and
the first thing he did was tell
reporters is here to win the election
president Trump also weighing in calling
out Broward County's history of election
problems if you look at Broward County
they have had a horrible history and if
you look at they the person in this case
a woman involved she has had a horrible
history and all of a sudden they're
finding votes out of nowhere and Rick
Scott who won by you know it was close
but he won by a comfortable margin every
couple of hours it goes down a little
bit they hire lawyers and the votes
don't ever seem to go the Republican way
it is interesting it always seems to go
the way of the Democrats Broward County
election supervisor Brenda Snipes
taking the brunt of the criticism just
yesterday she couldn't give an answer on
how many ballots are left to be counted
you just update us where things are on
the count
just in general could I please get a
moment to go into the room advantage
okay
and this just breaking a judge siding
with Rick Scott's campaign and is
ordering Brenda Snipes to allow
immediate inspection of voter records
before 7:00 p.m. Eastern tonight so this
feels like deja vu all over again and
you just saw something on the Twitter's
yes and as you know I love to break news
and I have breaking news right here on
my phone I'm gonna get to it right now
I'm gonna start reading this from my
phone okay here we go with some breaking
news this is a tweet from Marco Rubio
you might remember him from running for
president and I believe he's a senator
of Florida yes yes thank you little
Marco a little ado and troubling
allegation has emerged a statement under
penalty of perjury that Palm Beach
County filled out new ballots to replace
damaged ones without allowing campaign
representatives to witness the process
of creating the new ballot which is
required by Florida so basically here
you have this is my interpretation not
Marcos that here you have Democrats who
have been screaming and yelling about
Russian collusion in interfering with
elections and all the time the call has
been coming from inside the house it's
the Democrats who are colluding and
interfering with elections how
convenient that they find these votes
after they lose this is interesting that
it took us a long time to finally call
that race on election night Murray you
were sitting there with us we and
actually Rick Scott the governor gave a
victory speech before FoxNews had
actually called the election it was
close for but then he did and then right
after his victory speeches when Fox News
decision desk made the call but Nelson
never conceded and then he hired mark
Elias who is of election Fame right he
was Al Franken's lawyer when norm
coleman lost in 2008 yes and endless MC
vote needs to be counted this is we're
not even into Arrigo the talking points
always get counted well so look it needs
to be done transparently and a judge has
ruled now that they need to be more
transparent in Broward County and I
think that that's a good thing this is
only the initial count we're not even
into the question of a recount and
they're close enough definitely one of
the races is close enough
race the governor's race could end up
close enough as well but there is as of
this point 504 on the East Coast on
Friday there is no evidence that we have
seen a voter fraud there's a lot of
allegations there's a lot of people who
have partisan interests in these races
making claims and we just need to take a
deep breath we need to have some
transparency we need to get the votes
counted and we also though going forward
need to make our election systems better
in terms of how we do this Arizona like
voter ID Arizona is still voting
counting votes California still counting
votes there are a lot of mailings 18
years after the 2000 recount Fiasco the
fact that Florida has not fixed their
system is actually pretty crazy Jesse
what do you think of all this well he
started out Tuesday night he's got a
60,000 vote margin so he thinks he's got
it because the bush recount Bush at the
end of that night only had a 2000 vote
margin so very comfortable and then a
day goes by and all these votes come in
from Brower kinda fishy and he sleeps on
it and he wakes up and there's a more
votes coming in from Broward the votes
coming in from Broward three-to-one
Democrat and that's a two-to-one
Democrat at best kind of County all
right and now he squeezed it down to
15,000 vote margin triggering a recount
very interesting now listen this woman
we're talking about right now snipes we
call her sneaky Snipes already she's got
her we do we that's what we call because
she's got a history of this she's been
already accused of ballot stuffing of
hiding amendments from ballots a judge
has ruled that she illegally destroyed
ballots not in this case but in this
case in 2016 and in 2018 she was accused
of not allowing Scott's representatives
to watch her fill out provisional
ballots and the judge just smacked her
down and says it's time to open up the
doors because you're doing everything in
secret her number one job is to know how
many ballots were cast how many were
counted and how many are left to be
counted she says she has no idea and the
fact that she's not communicating to the
public or to the campaigns how many
votes cast counted and to be counted is
suspicious because if you don't know the
tabulation then anything could happen
underneath and that's why this woman
no one has faith in her at all because
especially the way she's conducted
herself this day and two years ago
there's there's no evidence you ever see
that bigger day you had one job George
of elections you don't know how many
boats are yeah if there was ever me
mobile material that you had one job he
sniped you can't even count the votes
now a couple of things here number one
there may not be direct evidence of
fraud but evidence of irregularities is
everywhere they had to have the votes
posted 30 minutes after the polls closed
they didn't that's just a matter of fact
and another thing
yes I agree with you every vote should
be counted absolutely had some that
should go across the aisle the question
is when what is Florida doing late
voting now so now we're doing early post
election ballot Democrats are
outperforming Republicans in the lake
they're counting votes that were cast on
Election Day they are slow to count in
Florida they're slow to count in Lawton
state points stipulated the problem is
as Greg accurately stated she doesn't
even know how many votes are to be
counted to the campaigns or to the
public what the vote count is she hired
by law
well the judge ruled against her you're
right and by 7:00 p.m. tonight they said
she had to put those numbers out I think
she should be more transparent I just
don't think we should jump to the
conclusion that because the race is
tightening which often happens when
provisional ballots get counted that
there's somehow fraud we have to wait
for evidence just because the one who's
seeing it has a history of fraud sure
evidence means that what you think it
means like there is significant evidence
of irregularities going on here she is
not how do you not have the vote count
point out voter fraud evidence but she
didn't even report she's not letting
people in to actually watch I fill out
the provisional we don't know that
evidence especially will make
would they file a lawsuit they just
wanted to work they wallow the lawsuit
if you're already watching their father
lawsuit because they've been barred they
want look a lot of these lawsuits that
we're gonna see during these recounts
are going to be shaky illegal ground but
done for partisan political reasons that
happens in every recount we've seen that
we just have to let the evidence take us
where it's kind of amazing and that you
I mean it and it's not good
Gregg will go back to you that either
way yes half of the population there in
Florida will think that the other half
did something to steal this election
from them that's not good it's if the
Dems just want to make America suffer
it's like losing the World Series in
demanding an extra-inning
a day later I have a new nickname by the
way for Bill Nelson recount Dracula
anyway but we predicted this I think
last week we said that no matter what
the outcome was whether the Dems we're
gonna win are gonna be or lose they
weren't gonna be happy because they were
just this is too much of their life
I'm Hui but you're different Murray
you're a very pleasant person can I say
one thing though I lost an election by
one point and I want an election day and
lost on an absentee count I conceded and
you can go to the Daily Caller article I
adore a very nice letter to John Delaney
was now running for president and said
it's not even people encouraging me to
file a lawsuit it's time to move on this
is BS that you know are real
irregularities according to the rules
why did they just use in court why did
they just lose in court why does she not
post 30 minutes after like she was
supposed to she's gonna have to tonight
the lesson is never concede and then we
laughed about it and Bill Nelson never
conceded but Andrew Gilliam did and now
that one also could end up at a recast
room recount Dracula we're on our game
tonight